the singer Jewel performed the national
anthem at the Indy 500 and it has
divided the public and this is a so I
have to get up on my my soapbox so I've
done my soapbox I'm just switching
soapboxes to a different one you know as
we shift soapboxes throughout the show
uh but this is this is important so so
we're gonna play it's a little snippet
of this this is the Anthem that she
performed and there are some people that
loved it so she had a beautiful voice it
was great other people that that thought
it was an atrocity
um I will tell you what the correct
position is after we watch a little bit
of this go ahead
[Music]
what surprised
at the time
[Music]
so I'm going to deliver the verdict here
this is uh uh this is this is bad
um this is bad this is treason you know
I think you can make an argument that we
would arrest people who performed I
think if you yeah okay I'm committing to
this it just popped in my head I think
that if you perform the National Anthem
with an acoustic guitar you should go to
prison
and
be executed
um yes
I'm calling for the execution of Jewel
for for performing with her maybe not
that far but at least like at least a
steep fine okay we'll settle we started
with execution we'll go down I think a
steep fine for performing the uh the
National Anthem with an acoustic guitar
look she's a she's an obviously a very
talented singer and she has a beautiful
voice
that's that makes the offense even worse
because she could have performed it
traditionally and it would have been a
very good performance
um
any attempt to turn the national anthem
into an acoustic folk ballad will always
be terrible and I'm not saying that
because I have some sort of prejudice
against acoustic folk ballots I don't I
love that kind of music I mean in
acoustic folk value you take someone
with a great voice and they're just
strumming the acoustic guitar and
singing a song
as long as it's not the anthem I will
almost all as long as it's not the
anthem and it's not happening in church
okay
as long as that's not the case I will
almost always like the song I love all
those kinds of songs
if it's not the anthem it's not a church
so I have no prejudice against that
genre of music I very much enjoy that
music but uh that's not the national
anthem
and you need to stop trying to make the
anthem you know sound modern or whatever
it's supposed to sound like an Anthem
like the national anthem is a certain
song and that's what it is and so if you
do it another way you're not performing
The Anthem anymore you're doing
something else it doesn't even it looks
almost weird when someone's performing
The Anthem that way to have people in a
stadium standing there with their hands
on their heart it looks strange because
it's not the answer she's not performing
The Anthem this is just her she's made
it about herself this is a singer going
out and saying well I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna just perform the anthem
because that'd be boring to me and I
want this to be a moment for me and so
I'm going to put on a pop performance or
acoustic folk performance and that's all
it is it's just a little musical number
it's it's not really the anthem anymore
and uh and so it looks the Optics looks
strange it's like can you imagine people
at an acoustic folk concert standing
there with their hands on their hearts
doesn't make any sense uh the anthem is
supposed to sound a certain way and
that's what it is if you do it a
different way not the anthem anymore
um
it's not supposed to sound like a song
on your Spotify playlist
yeah the actual national anthem it's not
really catchy
in no other context would you listen to
a song like that
you're not you're not going to put it on
your Spotify playlist and listen to it
in the car while you're driving along on
a road trip you're not going to do that
but it's not that's not what that's not
its function the song has a certain
function
and uh and this is not it
so that is incorrect
life in prison
we're back up to that for that I'll do
it for this portion shows and move over
to the members block you can become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed